imposing and intriguing this giant
building breaks the monotony of its
surroundings its terracotta color and
geometric layout are unusual for a
school in Western India in general most
people look at schools hospitals you
know in a very straight line manner
without thinking of spaces for social
interaction for how to make it you know
Lively for the residents because people
are spending like half a day there the
school is part of the spotty hectare
Township in Rajasthan State most
residents are employees of a cement
factory the region is hot and dry
the architect has taken the climate into
consideration in his design thick
angular pillars shelter Open Spaces even
in the scorching Sun temperatures here
can reach 45 degrees Celsius so the
auditorium faces South and blocks much
of the sunlight classrooms are on the
opposite side facing north so they get
less heat during school hours joining
them is this giant pergola where
students gather for extracurricular
activities and it does feel cooler here
two sets of vertical walls further
restrict directs on light
inside classrooms are well lit and there
is no need for air conditioning curtains
or blinds the corridors are modeled on
Village streets twisting and turning
creating Nooks for students it's not
just about the aesthetic I truly believe
that this infrastructure is also
designed in such a beautiful way that it
meets all our requirements mathematic
teacher they use this space they teach
geometry to the students and we also
provide students free time to interact
among themselves
the school was built five years ago and
is inspired by the Region's traditional
architecture
sanjapuri says he drew from his own
experience so studying in Rajasthan was
very interesting because we were in a
school that has a lot of history and
what is there to learn is that the
traditional way of building was actually
much better you did not need air
conditioning you did not need any kind
of you know additional shelter because
it was already provided for
he hopes to encourage students to
interact more teachers say students
enjoy the space and learn better
Al Jazeera Ross Western India